let's go next to our caller from the
five one three area code who's calling
today from 523 this is John from Ohio
hey John what's up um so we only just
started getting some recognition of the
Tara Reid story like in the mainstream
media but it still isn't getting the
like attention that I think it should
did um do you ever take on like why that
is or do you have like a taker opinion
on the issue in general well listen I
mean my view has always been that people
who come forward and say this happened
to me should be heard and their claims
should be taken seriously and
investigated and that's my view
regardless of who's being accused of
political or political party full-stop
right I mean that that's my view and
then you know that there should be a
full and proper investigation in terms
of why it's not getting more coverage in
corporate media I have two ideas about
that one is that there is skepticism
among some in corporate media about
elements of the story now I'm not an
expert on the story so it would sort of
be beyond me to go through all of those
details now just on the basis of your
phone call you know I'm not not prepared
to do that right now nor do I think that
it's necessarily the the best thing to
be doing but I think part of what's
holding down coverage in corporate media
is skepticism of some elements of the
story and whether that's right or wrong
is a real debate to be had right I mean
if you believe that accusers allegations
should be taken seriously then you know
take them seriously and investigate and
then I think the second thing is also
we're just in a crazy situation with
coronavirus constantly and a lot of
stories that would normally get more
attention you know stuff stuff related
to insane government corruption that
would normally at least make more of a
blip the Tara Reid story arguably is
part of that you know some recent thing
that's being widely misinterpreted about
UFOs but still it's there's a lot of
stories that I think were it not for
coronavirus would be getting a lot more
attention
okay that's all I wanted it No alright
my friend thank you great to hear from
you very much appreciate it